We were promised a non-terrifying hedgehog,
and by gosh, it looks like we'll get one.
On October 26th, a Sonic fan account on Twitter
posted a picture of a standee for the upcoming
film Sonic the Hedgehog that appears to confirm
that recently leaked images of the title character's
redesigned look were genuine.
Assuming that the new photo of the standee
isn't doctored, it sure looks like somebody
really did have a friend at Paramount who
managed to smuggle out artwork featuring Sonic's
new design.
In contrast to the version of the speedy blue
hedgehog featured in the movie's first trailer,
Sonic now looks much, much more video game-y,
and much less like the result of some terrifyingly
unethical genetics experiment.
As you can see, the look is classic Sonic,
from the shape of his eyes to his gloved hands
to his body, which is far less humanoid.
This lines right up with the two images that
were previously leaked, one of which appears
to actually be the same image used on the
standee, and the other which shows the character
from the front.
Another thing the images have in common?
Neither of them seem likely to give you nightmares,
like the old design did.
The flick's director, Jeff Fowler, and his
VFX team going back to the drawing board like
this is unusual.
It's the only time we can think of that massive
fan outcry in response to a film's promotional
materials was acknowledged and the issue corrected.
Fowler and his crew even pushed back the movie's
initial release date of November 8 by several
months to allow them time to properly dial
in Sonic's look.
Basically, the team responsible for Sonic's
design got just about everything wrong that
they possibly could have gotten wrong the
first time around.
Those weird-looking, almost human eyes look
nothing like what we're used to from Sonic,
but they're totally spot-on when compared
to the teeth, which simply appear to be a
set of actual human teeth, for some mysterious
reason.
Did anyone really want Sonic to have people
teeth?
"No, but thank you for asking."
The design of Sonic's body wasn't any better.
Once again, the animators leaned into giving
the fuzzy little guy oddly human proportions,
including hands and feet that were much smaller
than Sonic's video game look, and legs that
could only be described as "disturbingly buff."
"Gotta work out year-round, little bro.
It's part of being healthy."
While the trailer made the movie itself look
pretty fun, and promised a return to gonzo
comic form by Jim Carrey, fans simply couldn't
get past the fact that their beloved hedgehog
looked so unfamiliar and off-putting, and
they took to Twitter in droves to let Fowler
and company know about it.
To his credit, Fowler responded almost immediately,
and what he had to say went a long way toward
soothing angry Sonic fans.
In a tweet, the director wrote,
"Thank you for the support.
And the criticism.
The message is loud and clear...you aren't
happy with the design & you want changes.
It's going to happen.
Everyone at Paramount & Sega are fully committed
to making this character the BEST he can be."
A few weeks later, Fowler announced via Twitter
that the flick had been pushed back in order
to allow him and his team, quote, "a little
more time to make Sonic just right."
That was pretty much the last we'd heard of
the whole thing until those leaked images
hit the web, and it's pretty obvious that
the flick's VFX artists have been busting
their butts making sure that Sonic looks as
video game-accurate as possible.
Fans across Twitter breathed a collective
sigh of relief in response to Sonic's new
look, and it's likely just a matter of time
before we get a new trailer featuring the
rejiggered design, and probably a winking
in-joke or two about the initial design's
reception.
That original trailer will live on in infamy
until the heat death of the internet, though,
and will serve as a timeless example of how
not to render iconic video game characters
so that they look like something your child
is convinced hides under their bed every night.
Sonic the Hedgehog comes sprinting into theaters
on February 14th, 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more SVG videos about your favorite
things are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.